all right I got to ask you about my
kitchen rules because you brought up
baking my kitchen rules this you're
doing this No thank you I'm good okay
it's just surreal it's drink can I get a
scotch
I'm okay
My Kitchen Rules this is a show you're
doing with your former wife you guys are
divorced what's going on why are we but
not like the way you think we're talking
about well we're still together but
you're divorced yeah we know we never
broke apart what happened is it was like
a beautiful day in LA you know and I
came outside and I said I got a great
idea why don't we go get divorced you
know and then we could go get dinner and
and we went with that because I don't
like the threat of divorce in a marriage
I've been married a ton of times you
know I don't understand you guys got
divorced right but we let divorce to
save the relationship so you live with
her and you're together but you're
divorced yeah the right way I guess I'm
an idiot well how many years are you
married now I'm married now Jesus 15
years all right you got your own bedroom
no okay that's your first mistake
[Laughter]
[Applause]
because this isn't like the Stone Age
right right from years ago where couples
got to sleep together get up together
right you want to go to sleep you turn
off your little nightlight and she's
there with a laptop with the big glow
and you're pretending you're in the dark
to go to sleep right and they're sending
emails and texts and all the garbage
that we got a deal with today so you've
got a divorced but you let you sleep in
a separate room then well but we're
together a lot cuz you know we bang a
lot you know which I'm which I'm
professional life so is that a tattoo
out on TV bang today TV TV these days is
mostly banging yeah
that's all it is so you're like mr.
Rogers practically out here exactly this
way you got your own space I could smoke
my cigarettes I could hang out right so
you and your wife who stole your wife
but you're divorced you do this show
together and you and it's a it's about
cooking is that right yeah it's a
cooking competition and I was thrilled
to do it because honestly Valerie my
wife whatever you want to call her you
know your ex-wife that you call her an
ex-wife when I introduced I go this is
my wife who I divorced she sort of
divorced me her name comes first on the
paperwork so uh so I just thought it
would
[Music]
you're like this is like I met an
interesting guy at a bar this is no way
as a talk-show well well the thing is
what was great about it is like when
when Fox offered me the show I thought
it would be a great opportunity for her
yeah because she's a pretty great cook
yeah and it was great to see her rise to
the occasion to do to accomplish
something yes you know that that she did
and it was just so much fun to do and we
never did cook together so I got in a
lot of trouble on the show yeah you know
she'd yell at me you know yeah yeah and
I would tell her you know my friend this
is TV my friends are watching this yeah
me you know but she's unbelievable in an
unbelievable person and I'm glad I'm
with her and I'm glad I love it the way
I do well it was I'm seeing you in a
bunch of years it's nice to see you
again my Kitchen Rules airs Thursdays at
9:00 on Fox television Andrew Dice Clay
we'll be right back awesome
you